You mentioned running a Syrex test before which one would be good for a cancer patient?
So it really depends on so remember just because the person has cancer doesn't mean that they don't have other
Comorbidities and they may have other
Comorbidities that could kill them before the cancer. So you do want to you know not
Not address those things
so
Syrex testing is is antibody testing most of the side will we run Syrex test for testing for antibodies?
That's why we use the Syrex lambs. They do have some other lymphocyte panels and stuff that we don't use as much
But typically we're using Syrex to run antibody tests
Why would a cancer patient want to run antibody tests? Well multiple reasons if you're looking for the health of the gut
Then you would run Syrex array 2 which is going to test for gut permeability factors remember there's three different levels of
leaky gutter gut permeability, so we would want to see
You know what level of gut permeability this person is dealing with if they have got problems Syrex 3 and 4
tell us
Break down
Gliann, which is the protein of gluten into its components the peptide components and we're measuring if the person has antibodies to that
And certainly
Gliann peptide issues are common with cancer, which are commonly lead to hyperinflammatory
Responses elsewhere their body and remember if you have food antibodies if you're every time you eat something
That you don't even know you have an antibody to you're going to cause this inflammatory response in the gut and now you have your immune system fighting
Battles at other fronts, so it's like okay if we would have went into World War 2 in Japan would have never
Attacked us and they were going to be our allies and friends and we were fighting Hitler
It would have been a lot weaker to come to the conclusion of defeating
The Nazis because we wouldn't have been split trying to fight the battle at two fronts for same thing with our body if we have food antibodies
that were not aware of and
Every time we eat that food, it's causing an inflammatory response in the gut the immune system is having to split its
forces instead of trying to just kill the cancer. It's dealing with this inflammatory response in the gut and it certainly would be
Beneficial if we could rule things out and clean things up and help heal the gut
That's why we have most of you people on a drink mix that is got a lot of gut healing things in there as well
And you know supporting detoxification pathways and supporting gut health so that we can cold that down but to run Cyrex panels
to test for that and to
to kind of
You know
Clean that up and discover what I need to change though
That aspect I'd say array two array three array four and array 10
So that's where we get into really the gut healing things for
To help
Call that in inflammatory response, you know in the gut
And then if you want to look at other comorbidities do I have antibodies to other tissues that I'm you know have
autoimmune diseases that are yet diagnosed that I've never discovered because I then looking at array five
Which tests a lot of antibodies to different tissues and array seven X which gets into details of antibodies to
neurological tissue
Then you could do array 11 and array 12 which is I don't run those very often
That's if you have antibodies to different toxins and different pathogens
They don't run those very often because they I don't think that they really give us the big they tell us a lot but they don't like
Give us a lot to
Treat that you're already kind of treating that so it to me you run a lab if it's gonna really change the way you're going to care for the patient
Not just to gain information so
That's what I would look at